[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce dernier magazine pape
de la saison nous sur lequel nous allons
revenir sur un certain nombre
d'événements de l'année vous nous allons
nous projeter dans l'est dont les mois
dans les années qui viennent avec
nathalie est positif
bonjour vous êtes invités des 6e
circonscription des yvelines députés l
herbe
m et on va parler avec vous évidemment
des événements de l'année mais aussi des
projets parce que beaucoup de projets
pour les mois qui viennent et puis de ce
qu'est le mandat d'un député vous avez
été élu pour la première fois il ya deux
ans donc maintenant vous avez une
expérience à nous raconter lionel masse
et à jour vous a demandé au directeur de
50 de 2,50 ap
on va parler de culture parce que on
verra peut-être que justement dans le ja
des scissions dans la société française
peut-être que la culture est un des
points d'ancrage des points de
rassemblement de cette société on va
revoir parler puis il ya aussi tout le
programme à venir des tables de saint
quentin est pas un meeting jeudi un
arbitrage en invitant ses habitués le
directeur du golf national vous avez eu
une année chargée peu kamen attaqué
plusieurs et comme écrin lieu mais c'est
aussi parce qu'il y avait eu aussi une
cité qui était ce sera seulement
formidable où vous prenez un thème
chaque année et cette année c'était
c'était le c'était ce qu'on mange
c'était très intéressant pour l'héritage
il ya évidemment la ryder cup cette
année témoin qui a été qui était une
grande réussite
merci il ya avoir parlé quand même il ya
l'open de france qui se
qui sera au mois d'octobre c'est vrai
pour changer pour changer et puis vous
avez une passionnante interview dans
l'équipe sur l'évolution possible de la
consommation c'est auprès dire 10 golf
la pratique je pense pas puisque enfin
3.0 l'avenir du seul voile à vizille
holtz et c'est passionnant dans lequel
aussi rentrer la perspective écologique
et on va reparler mais peut-être une
question tout de suite d'actualité avec
vous d'un télégraphe le bac
résultat aujourd'hui peut-être tous les
résultats peut-être pas tous les
résultats il ya une grève dans certain
nombre d'examinateurs de profs
enfin 10 et une prise d'otages s'est
quand même mal vécue et je poste de la
part d'eads et des familles comment vous
comprenez que des enseignants puissent
en arriver peut-être quand même ce qui
est un peu extrême quand même comme
comme réaction parce que le bac c'est
quand même quelque chose de ma première
pensée va d'abord aux bacheliers qui
attendent le résultat certains peut-être
commencer à les avoir
donc moi je n'ai pas trop d'inquiétude
sur le fait que les les
les résultats seront annoncés
aujourd'hui parce que parce que en fait
il ya un petit nombre très minoritaire
de copies qui ont été gardés en réserve
de certains professeurs mécontents donc
la grande majorité n'est pas concernée
et puis sur les les quelque dix mille ou
trente mille cas
il y à cette possibilité de prendre la
note de contrôle continu donc j'ai pas
les pages pas d'inquiétude je veux
montrer rassurante et est vraiment pensé
aux bacheliers à leurs familles
notamment une bachelière ma fille dans
j'attends à face à ce double casquette
concernés mais oui oui vous savez les
élus ne sont pas hors sol de citoyens
comme les autres donc je regarde depuis
ce matin les sites et donc on peut pas
comprendre en tant que parent on se dit
on est prise en otage c'est quand même
insupportable et puis en tant que
politique
moi je sais que j'ai rencontré pas mal
de représentants du corps enseignant
j'ai été moi-même aussi pendant quatre
ans enseignante
donc je sais la pression je sais les
attentes qui sont vives mais là je pense
qu'il ya une 1re fut une opposition
changement qui est un petit peu
dogmatique
je comprends que c'est difficile pour
eux sur lequel seul le fait d'adapter
pour les enseignants pour de s'adapter à
un grand changement qui est en train se
passer dans la réforme du secondaire
mais franchement honnêtement qui pouvait
se satisfaire de cette répartition
filière littéraire es s où il y avait
une sélection tous les meilleurs aux
élèves les uns mais franchement sans
avoir de d'ambition particulière dans
les sciences c'est s était pas c'était
pas équilibré et là on offre un meilleur
projet aux élèves
je sais que les périodes de transitions
sont toujours les plus celle qui nous
remue le plus mais qu'est ce que c'est
beau de pouvoir se dire ben je suis je
suis plutôt littéraire mais j'ai envie
de faire un peu de science où je suis
matin mais j'ai envie de faire du latin
et 2002
et c'est répondre à une aspiration plus
naturelle des élèves et pour avoir connu
d'autres cure 6 comme ceux qui sont
enseignés dans à l'étranger qui
fonctionne sur le site air mais dieu
s'ils s'améliorent à une maille ne vous
à vous demander aux élèves qui ont connu
ces systèmes là ils sont beaucoup plus
heureux beaucoup plus épanouie donc
c'est pour le bien des élèves donc je
comprends les réticences au changement
mais alors il est pas admissible de
prendre les nommés chevaliers en otage
on va revenir sur les réticences
peut-être changement pour les remises et
de vous avez fait vos études
j'ai fait une maîtrise universitaire en
angleterre ne donne donc un pays
d'origine et ducati des entraînements
oui oui complètement complètement et
même en 91 juju ma maîtrise avant de
venir en france international business
paris nantes c'était finance
internationale est effectivement moi
j'ai spécialisés à partir de l'âge de 15
ans en angleterre j'ai fait économie et
langues étrangères où j'ai commencé à
toucher un petit peu le français et
l'espagnol en âge de 16 ans et puis
après tout de suite en université
j'avais un majeur qui était économie
donc on choisit ses à cevital rétro très
tôt d'une halle b c'est à vous de le rue
du bac
je me souviens
c'est bien moi j'ai fait après le bac il
a fait du droit
j'avais fait une j'avais en au lycée
j'ai choisi une filière littéraire et
c'est assez amusant parce que cette
réforme du bac corrobore assez bien
parce que je pense de ce que doit être
l'enseignement est ce que je dis à mes
filles la science aaas à comprendre le
monde
le français le français ou les landes
en tout cas tu les matières littéraires
ça sert à l'expliquer donc je pense que
les deux sont totalement totalement
loupé l'année avec le mentir tout avait
effectivement cette hyper spécialisation
d'autant plus que moi j'ai eu un
parcours un peu pas heurté mais en tout
cas des changements assez radicaux entre
des études littéraires ensuite le droit
une profession de juriste et ensuite une
réorientation dans le domaine culturel
et artistique
donc je trouve ça tellement impossible
pour des gamins de 16 ans 17 ans 18 ans
de choisir si tôt une orientation qu'il
faut avoir une visée la plus large
possible
je crois que c'est ce qu'offre cette
réforme d'ouverture disciplinaire
effectivement et d'inciter les élèves à
aller vers ce qu'ils aiment ce qu'ils
ressentent et pas de les mettre dans une
section particulière fonctionne juste de
résultat et ça ne doit-elle pas bon que
les littéraires en gros c'était un peu
ça qu'on réinvente les élèves puissent
suivre leur leurs plantations et qu'ils
aillent vers là où ils ont de
l'appétence voilà en plus très compliqué
c'est vrai quand il ya eu au cours des
dernières années
l'évolution est comme ça n'oublie
gassion choix assez rapide assétou à 16
ans 17 ans n'est pas forcément sait pas
exactement ce qu'on va faire plus tard
on n'a pas forcément le vous saviez à
peu près mais au nom mais bon difficile
exactement exactement en fait justement
quand j'ai choisi ça je ne savais pas
exactement ce que je voulais mais je
sais que on
voyageons un peu avec mon sac à dos j'ai
mais j'ai mes voyages et j'aimais les
autres cultures je vais voir du monde
dingue langues étrangères avec un peu de
finances s'étaient c'était bon steven
j'avais envie de faire à ce moment là et
maintenant travailler dans le golfe est
arrivé là là où je suis aujourd'hui non
la vie est longue mais je veux dire
qu'elle est qu ici voilà mes parcours
pour vous aussi
oui c'est sa troisième carrière ma
deuxième vie mais c'est bien d'avoir
plusieurs et c'est bien pour moi c'est
une chance et un ces six mois le luxe
parce que bon il faut se se se défier à
se mettre au défi soi même et se
réinventer et c'est possible donc je
pense que c'est plus facile pour
certains que d'autres il faut avoir
effectivement une certaine confiance en
soi et la confiance on l'acquiert déjà
dansé dans ses études à l'école et c'est
là aussi où la réforme du scolaire mais
plus large pas seulement du secondaire
mais ce qu'on cherche à apporter aussi
aux enfants dès la maternelle dans les
réformes du ministre blanc caire en
réduisant les effectifs on cherche à
personnaliser plus l'accompagnement et
puis à développer et d des capacités
d'expression à l'oral et de prise de
confiance c'est quand même ce qui manque
peut-être un petit peu dans notre dans
notre enseignement actuelle qui est
parfois effectivement très stéréotypé et
heureusement la plupart des enseignants
accompagne maintenant sept
ce changement de paradigme pour pour
avoir dévalé des enfants qu'ils soient à
l'aise qu'ils puissent ensuite
s'exprimer et et dans la vie voilà il
faut avoir confiance et je crois que
c'est un vin c'est important pour tout
au long de sa vie pour tenter des choses
non mais c'est vrai que moi moi j'ai été
confronté aussi à l'enseignement aux
etats unis puisque ce parti aux états
unis pendant les pendant mes études
et c'est vrai qu'on est dans des douves
parliez de la question de la confiance
en soi
on est sur des modes d'enseignement qui
sont totalement différent tout
simplement parce que le le professeur à
quelqu'un qui guident la réflexion
l'élève ou l'étudiant à quelqu'un qui
participe très activement à la
construction de son savoir
je dis pas que je ne renie pas
l'enseignement français qui je me
lalande l'enseignement en france qui je
pense est d'une immense qualité parce
que je crois qu'on a tous dans notre
dans notre scolarité soit ou à l'école
de collèges lycées universités rencontré
will professeur promettez des
déclencheurs moi je sais que j'ai eu il
ya quelques années on peut les compter
les endroits de la main mais il ya notre
os 4 qui nous ont marqués oui mais c'est
important c'est très rare multiplie sa
part le nombre le nombre d'élèves est là
donc il ya des déclencheurs qui sont
peut-être réseau quand on est dans un
système scolaire qui au lieu de
valoriser la réussite wiki contre un
incendie sur un peu sanctionne oui c'est
vrai
et surtout et moi je me rends compte
avec des enfants en bas âge que si des
enfants ne sont pas faits pour ce modèle
d'enseignement là c'est très compliqué
pour c'est à dire dans l'impression
qu'il n'y a qu'un seul modèle
d'enseignement et que ce modèle n'est
pas forcément adaptable c'est pour ça
qu'on compte compte aussi sur le sur le
tac et le talent des professeurs pour
arriver à s'adapter aux élèves mais oui
sur le font de plus en plus ça de toute
façon la société change les enseignants
se doivent d'accompagner les changements
il ya aussi la question qui se pose
c'est là où nous devons les aider et
leur apporter des réponses en tant que
politique il faut qu'il soit dans un
climat serein et aujourd'hui il ya quand
même des comportements à l'école qui
sont difficiles à gérer
c'est pour ça que déjà réduire les
effectifs c'est déjà une première
avancée et s'est passé avec le
dédoublement des classes
nous sommes sûrs et ses heures ça marche
bien vous entendez les professeurs et
vous voyez ça change leurs méthodes
d'enseignement moi j'ai visité à
carrières sous poissy des écoles
puisqu'ils sont en zone rep et déjà vous
rentrez dans la salle vous percevez une
grande différence convient que douze
élèves c'est le niveau de bruit et le
niveau de chaleur parce que la
température est beaucoup plus basse
quand vous avez des classes à 30 élèves
je peux vous dire que ça ça produit
beaucoup de d'énergie là vous avez un
climat plus serein
les élèves qui sont organisés en groupes
qui travaillent en autonomie et un
enseignant qui circulent autour et qui
donne des conseils personnalisés à huy
qui pouvait faire ceci et en
l'enseignement est radicalement
différent
donc pour moi c'est la clé parler de 2,3
vie enfin le professionnel c'est là des
assistés il ya quelques jours c'était de
serbie qui sont assez émouvante ses deux
médailles du travail alors ont
récompensé on compense les gens qui
avaient 20 ans ou 30 ans dans la même
entreprise et je me disais en deux alors
c'était très émouvant comme pour les
gens qui recevait ccc bétail mais
c'était on a quand même changé deux
autres forts compenser des gens qui
restait le plus autant dans le même
temps le même travail aujourd'hui on
essaye de favoriser justement les
changements de vie les changements de
travail les mobilités
c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas en parler
dans nos cultures en sport on est à un
moment de basculement quand même de nos
sociétés non et et en même temps et vous
repasserez
justement ça explique peut-être cela il
ya la fois une volonté de changer d'un
certain nombre de gens et une réticence
au changement de l'autre et c'est
compliqué quand on gouvernement sont les
nouvelles générations de toute façon
qu'ils vont imprimer le pas à venir faut
avoir l'humilité de reconnaître que on
peut pas on peut anticiper ce que sera
la société de demain c'est ce qu'on
essaye de faire une entente politique
mais on n'est pas sûr de prévoir tous
les coups alors on l'anticipent parce
que on mais on voit bien qu'il va y
avoir une transformation grâce au
numérique digital dont des nouvelles
formes de travail mais il ya des enjeux
société au des évolutions dont vous avez
les chercheurs maintenant qu'ils sont
des personnes qui occupent plusieurs
emplois en même temps donc une grande
diversité
il ya des impacts aussi haut niveau par
exemple la représentation des salariés
qui va défendre le droit de salariés qui
travaillent de jour ici trois jours là
c'est compliqué on voit bien que les
syndicats eux mêmes sont confrontés à
cette problématique il ya plus de
fidélisation de salariés comme ça sur le
long terme sur un seul à seul travail
c'était il ya des sociétés qui demandent
même alors qu'ils n'ont plus de salariés
mais qui ont des eaux qui sont qui
créent leur propre société
je pense qu'ils indépendant alors en
avant voilà quelques réformes que l'on a
fait parce que je crois que c'est
important
or en forme le on a renforcé le filet de
protection des travailleurs indépendants
parce que finalement vous créez votre
boîte ça marche pas vous retrouver au
chômage vous n'avez plus rien les femmes
ce qui qui qui qui ont cliqué qui font
un enfant et qui se retrouve sans son
endroit
gimont pour la maternité en fait donc là
on voit là les femmes d'artisans aussi
qu'ils vont être avoir une meilleure
protection à ce niveau-là lorsqu'elles
auront des enfants mais mais mais voilà
on peut accompagner et la société va
encore plus changé je pense du fait
effectivement de cette économie
numérique et puis de nos enfants moi je
vois bien dans un sens ils veulent pas
ils se projettent pas dans une seule
carrière
ils ont des appétits très divers et
variés on leur a offert le monde
pas forcément le plus beau mon petit
soin mais pas seulement ils sont
conscients et sont conscients de rester
là dessus ça fait deux ans que vous êtes
député un tout petit peu plus froid 2
quels sont les les qu'est ce que vous
retenez de ces deux ans qu'est ce qu'est
ce qui vous a surpris dans quand vous
êtes arrivé à l'assemblée nationale
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui vous a le le le
plus passionné alors on se rend compte
assez vite dès les premiers jours que
c'est pas un travail c'est pas un job
comme un autre on est dans une fonction
d'abord on rentre avec le sentiment de
grandes responsabilités ça je crois que
le premier jour on pénètre dans
l'hémicycle on se rend compte de la
charge qu'il y ait à tous de tous les
députés sont passés par là quels que
soient les partis
et puis je pense que même les plus
aguerris ce voilà on a des fauteuils sur
lesquelles on voit les noms de deux
prédécesseurs illustres donc on ne peut
qu être marquée par une solution
sonnette solennité pile histoire donc il
faut qu'on s'inscrive respectueusement
quand même dans une dans une tradition
nous nous sommes arrivés en masse une
nouvelle génération de nouveaux profils
willard et de vous et livrent de
nouveaux élus grand renouvellement une
mixité plus un parti surtout les gens
venant de la société civile qui ne sont
pas là par hasard comme le certains
l'ont entendu enfin ont voulu le dire ne
nous oppose en disant qu'on était sorti
à la d'une pochette surprise ou autre je
ne sais pas quoi d'un tirage au sort
c'est pas du tout ça c'est qu'on a tous
et parfois on a tous je construis des
parcours je peux vous donner des
exemples de personnes qui l assemblée
travaillent sur des sujets qu'elles ont
bien explorer
pendant leurs huîtres et qui avaient ce
taux véritable institution et volonté
alors voilà ça ensuite c'est une
fonction qui vont sur l'évolution une
mission qui pourraient être perdus quand
on arrive à peine à les persuader et au
sens propre comme au sens figuré
donc on est impressionné déjà c'est le
moment solennel et ensuite moi je me
rappelle tous venez les huissiers qui
sont là qui disent bienvenue chez vous
bienvenue dans votre maison
donc c'est voilà c'est pas l'image que
l'on a d'un travail classique et aussi
pourquoi une lisa six là dessus c'est
chez vous ben oui parce que vous allez y
passer beaucoup de temps et parce que et
yves et c'est vrai qu'on vit dans une
petite société quand même on y mange on
y dort on y travaille de jour de nuit
vous imaginez ce serait aussi prenons
par exemple avant d'être élu parce que
non parce que ce qui est difficile c'est
l' équilibre à trouver entre le temps
qu'on passe sur le terrain oui et le
temps qu'on est à paris et donc on
n'imagine pas toujours le temps perdu
aussi dans les transports où il ya des
temps d'attentes aussi on passe du temps
à attendre que voilà il ya des
amendements des discussions ça prend du
temps très très c'est pour ça qu'on a
mis en place une réforme du règlement
aussi on n'imagine pas le fait que des
discussions qui ont déjà eu lieu en
commission par exemple revienne et se
repassent sur le même modèle exactement
dans l'hémicycle quand on est habitué à
l'entreprise comme moi qui ai passé plus
de vingt cinq corps dans l'industrie
voilà on fait une réunion on décide on
ac et puis là les process sont
complètement différents j'essayais
d'ailleurs de rapides le travail
d'initiative et le fond le délai entre
la décision et le alors évidemment on va
revenir en quelques mots
bon qui vous qui a surpris tout le monde
qui vous a surpris je pense aussi ces
suidés gilet jaune que personne n'avait
vu venir
faut dire non alors est-ce qu'on ne
l'avait pas on aurait pu le voir venir
déjà on avait senti beaucoup de
mécontentement chez les retraités ça
c'est vrai que nous on le voyait sur le
terrain on recevait dans nos permanences
puisque les députés ont tous ses
permanences
beaucoup de retraités d'une part parce
qu'ils ont le temps puis parce qu'il
était vraiment très remonté le ils ont
eu l'impression que on le disait voilà
vous êtes des inactifs on vous prend de
l'argent c'est non il n'y a pas de de
sentiment c'est que les retouches sont
abusives et qui sont du tout utile donc
je pense qu'il ya eu en termes de
communication
en effet un peu jauni c'est à dire la
politique c'est arrivé c'est pas c'était
c'était ce qui était malheureux après on
a rectifié le tir
on a vu que les retraités si vous voulez
qu'ils subissent et 7 oz de csg de nax
finalement était parfois très limite en
termes de fin de mois
donc on a réaugmenté le plafond jusqu'à
2000 euros pour un voile a été levé
si avec le recul et ça voilà on
l'attendait le mécontentement beaucoup
plus sur les sur les retraités que sur
cette classe moyenne qui s'est exprimée
finalement avec le recul parce que les
villes de france il ya eu ce mouvement
auquel qui a fait la une de tous les
journaux de toutes les chaînes d'info
continue
électoralement ça s'est pas traduit
par lister les jonas ont rien fait il ya
probablement un gain pour le
rassemblement national
mais finalement il n'y a pas eu de drame
art et politique au contraire un aux
européennes notamment parce qu'il a pas
de structuration politique c'est pas moi
est ce que c'est parce qu'ils aient pas
de structuration politique est ce qu'on
n'a pas exagérer la force de ce
mouvement à ce que les médias n'ont pas
exagéré la force de ce mouvement
les images ont été violents dont je vais
pas blâmer les médias d'avoir fait des
couvertures en revanche c'est le je
trouve que le temps de parole qui a été
donnée à certains gilet jaune n'était
pas respectueux du temps de parole que
l'on donne normalement aux analyses qui
ont du recul ou aux politiques de tout
parti qui doivent s'exprimer et assumer
leurs responsabilités dire oui on
n'avait pas compris on n'avait pas vu là
on a eu de la parole brut qui s'est
déversé avec tout et n'importe quoi
c'est ce qui est aussi en partie
décrédibilisés ce mouvement c'est que
les revendications n'ont pas cessé de
changer de passer d'un sujet à l'autre
finalement et que même lorsqu'on
apporter des réponses lorsqu'on a mené
l'exercice d'expression voilà public du
grand débat national
bon ça j'arrive sur l'a77 7
mécontentement ce mécontentement mais
qui était hargneux dans s'en fout il
disait bon on veut mettre tous les élus
à la poubelle c'était un rejet de nos
institutions
je me sentais à huy véritablement un
héhéhé jeu et même au moment de la
campagne des européennes pourtant le
mouvement gilet jaune s'était un peu
calmé il y allait essayer d'y aller avec
délice et j'étais sur un plateau avec un
gilet jaune et juni mai mais c'est quoi
votre projet européen
il en avait pas y aller c'était vraiment
pour pour faire du bruit et il dit
finalement je le pousse oui mais qu'est
ce que qu'est ce que vous voulez eh bien
on veut mettre des citoyens à la place
voilà non à l'europe des citoyens au
gouvernement mais c'est parce que la
démocratie la démocratie par la
démocratie représentative n'est pas sa
compagne
rationaliser justement mouvement un peu
irrationnel ces quelques mots qu'est ce
que le poids essayé de faire avec le
grand débat c'est est ce que ça pose un
problème d'audition de culture ce genre
de mouvement ou est-ce que vous êtes que
j'étais très éloigné de bonnes on n'est
pas très éloigné puisque le théâtre nous
notre travail de terrain vous avez un
travail formidable dans le terme
d'intégration justement là le travail du
théâtre public s'est il ya d'un côté on
a déjà changé là dessus mais dont il ya
d'un côté la production la création la
diffusion d'oeuvres et de l'autre côté
le travail qu'on fait sur le terrain qui
représente vraiment 50% de notre travail
est ce que l'on ce que l'on la chimère
en tout cas qu'on poursuit c'est d'avoir
dans la salle des des publics qu'ils
soient représentatives de la sociologie
d'un territoire d'un territoire donné
c'est à dire qu'on fait en sorte que le
théâtre soit un lieu qu'ils soient
rassembleurs et pour revenir pour
revenir sur cette question et cette
crise d'idées gilet jaune moi je pense
que c'est que c'est le signe une un
besoin absolu d'être de se sentir
représentés et d'exister tout simplement
et que si cette crise a eu un aspect
positif c'est tout simplement de montrer
que la france la france ce n'est pas
uniquement la start up nation ce n'est
pas uniquement la france des auto
entrepreneurs des gens agile qui peuvent
s'adapter à tous les changements
sociétaux
mais c'est aussi la une france beaucoup
plus composites et ça je crois que les
bolides mais c'est une jument c'est un
cri qui s'adressent pas uniquement
politique ça s'adresse aux institutions
ça s'adresse au monde de la culture est
pas de france qui ne se disent regardez
ça s'adresse aux journalistes également
donc ça s'adresse à tous ceux qui tous
ceux qui semblent représenter la france
or la france est les composites comment
comment se sentent au frais de france
par c'est plus compliqué que ça mais en
fait c'est un petit peu ma vie
français une france de la réforme fasse
du bon moment et puis une france plus
traditionalistes et puis il me semble
sachez que ce que cette crise là va nous
obliger toussaint pas uniquement les
politiques là encore un jeune ballet
politique d'un côté et les autres va
tous nous obliger à réfléchir à cet
impensé qui est la question de la
réussite
qu'est ce que la réussite aujourd'hui le
seul modèle de réussite qui est proposé
c'est une réussite financière en la
réussite c'est bien plus complexe que ça
et si cette 7,7 cette crise permet à
tous ceux qui pensent être le plus
nombreux à penser cette question de la
réussite je pense souvent à quelque
chose de fondamental qu'est ce que la
réussite
la réussite individuelle notre liberté
individuelle comment la sauvegarde et on
y attacher et comment la sauvegarde et
pour la mettre au service aussi de
l'ensemble qui est plus grand et qui
nous dépasse donc c'est ça contient tous
à cette crise du gilet jaune c'est pour
ça qu'elle est très complexe à analyser
et les est complexe parce qu'elle est
très diffuses étions peut-on parler de
mouvement mais attendait il a dit
intérieurement il ya de ce mouvement il
ya des luttes entre addiction très fort
mais mais vous avez raison qu'il ya
quand même eu des aspects positifs
en effet sur le questionnement qu'on
peut avoir sur soi même sur la société
sur la démocratie quand même
il ya il ya en effet des efforts à faire
encore pour devenir plus démocratique
tout ça alors après je parle pas des
budgets économique mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on voit que le pouvoir
d'achat augmente on voit que c'est aussi
peut-être un effet collatéral des idées
je ne sais pas il y à ce que les deux
enseignements à tirer bien sûr de cette
crise s'était quand même test politique
qui a pikine où un parlementaire nous a
beaucoup affectés parce qu'on sait ni et
ont été ébranlés non dans nos valeurs
surtout nous qui sommes issues de la
société civile qui apportant ce
renouvellement et on se sent pas si
didier d'une politique moyens voilà on
n'était pas les feux sous nautique
armements et donc ça s'était très
perturbant 1 mais surtout ce qu'il faut
prendre il faut embrasser dans sa
globalité effectivement ces différences
ces divergences de points de vue qui
sont exprimés je crois qu'on a besoin
tout à fait du des intellectuels pour
prendre un peu de recul comme vous dites
repenser ce qui ce qui s'est dit à ce
moment là quel modèle de société
moi je crois que c'est fondamentalement
que c'est une nouvelle génération qui
vont nous donner des clés et ça passe
justement par ces mouvements étudiants
là mais la lutte contre le climat
mais pour les gilet jaune jeu
je crois que sur la partie sur ce qui
concerne plus de démocratie
participative
on a bien entendu le message et
d'ailleurs on l'avait entendu a tendance
à les faire entrer la proportionnelle on
voulait changer
on était sûr le point de le faire on n'a
pas eu le temps de mener ces réformes
qui devait passer parce que c'était
l'été dernier c'était d'affaires benalla
qui nous a empêchés de poursuivre notre
notre réforme sur la constitution on
était sur le point de réformer aussi par
exemple c'est the d'en faire un forum
citoyen pour associer plus les voilà et
cours pour ouvrir plus la part des
débats d ouvrir une réflexion y compris
sur les dangers doit aux citoyens il ya
aussi dans d'autres domaines enfin
probablement celle ça prend la place de
quoi ça prend la place des partis
politiques qui ne jouent plus leur rôle
d'évacuation des détentions et c'est
vrai que ça brise les os crise de la
démocratie telle qu'on l'a connue
pendant très longtemps donc et c'est
vrai que hier ce moment là mais il peut
y avoir d'autres noms du même genre qui
surgissent à tout moment il faut il faut
l'avoir en conscience et dire
qu'aujourd'hui c'est tout évolué il ya
les syndicats en moins de pouvoir
oui c'est tout à leur demande et les
partis politiques alors pas forcément
notre mouvement mais comment démêler
2,33 le ps 113% tous les deux aux
européennes c'est quand même un et il
est franchement très mous droite n'ont
pas réussi à récupérer ces mouvements
ils ne parlent plus n'ont plus accès à
ces revendications qui quand même émergé
d'une classe moyenne qui se sent et
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
ressort dit ben on est on est là
vraiment pour payer c'est pour ça que
l'on met en place c'est cette baisse
massive des impôts on reconnaît un
premier ministre l'a dit on reconnaît
qu' il ya une tranche voilà de la
population qui se sent matraquer
fiscalement et que et que quand il ya le
refus de l'impôt et ça c'est un
apprentissage aussi du mandat de députée
voyez le l'exercice budgétaire
il est structurant et moi je me suis
rendu compte à quel point ce qu'on
appelle le plf donc quand on définit le
budget allait à l'automne l'impôt est
juste que tu rentres le projet de loi de
finances et structurant pour la
politique que l'on a plus on applique à
la nation parce que c'est là où les gens
se lancent à se décider pivois
réellement les impacts des décisions
sont fait parfois des grandes annonces
politiques mais finalement c'est la
manière dont on prélève l'impôt on
touche ici à télé qui n'y comprend plus
ici on croit parce que c'est une
question d'équilibré budgétaire bien sûr
une fine et on ne peut pas ouvrir les
les dépendances en ajouter fst la peau
et bien
s'il n'ya pas d'acceptation d'impôts
c'est là où le politique se fait c'est
comme ça qui est l'un des boss de venir
s'y insérer impôts pas la méthode vous
avez vous ont pas été impactées
évidemment par le vent des filets jaunes
tourisme
quand même pas rien et qui peut impacter
je pense qu'un problème
qui en résultent d'image parce que et
l'image voilà c'est ce que je vous ai
demandé parce que vous avez beaucoup de
contacts avec des étrangers
comment s'était vu de est-ce qu'il ya
une inquiétude il ya alors moi je suis
actuellement en train de demander la
nationalité française pour des raisons
de par excès des choses comme ça donc je
parle là tant que français pas encore
j'attends toujours dans le vestiaire
mais donc je pars en tant que vous aimez
mais aussi en tant qu'étranger parce que
britannique
et c'est vrai que on commence à avoir
l'habitude entre guillemets ça commence
à être un petit peu la blague à
l'étranger et cancer dans les mouvements
en france et la limite je dirais de des
réclamations que peu à voir les gens
mais moi je voulais juste revenir sur
sur le mouvement dire que je pense qu'il
faut un peu demba romaine tu pense qu'il
faut un peu plus de participation parce
que sinon on va voir des mouvements de
plus en plus risqué dans ce sens là avec
les mulhousiens d'en discuter ce moment
le public avec les réseaux sociaux et et
c'est un peu comme le printemps arabe
il ya une dizaine d'années
je pense que ces mouvements peuvent
peuvent surgir beaucoup plus rapidement
donc je pense qu'il faut vraiment se
pencher sur sur la participation et la
communication
c'est vrai que les raisons d'une
nouvelle communication par les réseaux
sociaux la rapidité de l'information les
fausses informations et la défense
ajoutent ils ont une culture non
évidemment dites moi qu'est ce qui
change
l'arrivée justement des réseaux sociaux
des des nouvelles communications ça
change forcément parce qu'on doit en
tenir compte
après mon jeu je pense que ce que je dis
toujours c'est que le un théâtre où van
musée de la même façon est un lieu de
qui doit être connectée au monde qui est
par définition connectés au monde parce
que les artistes qui sont sur scène qui
sont en représentation représente aussi
le monde de l'extérieur ce sont des
produits les émanations du monde tel
qu'il est tel qu'il va mais c'est aussi
un lieu de déconnexion où on doit
pouvoir être totalement déconnecté
justement des réseaux sociaux être
connecté à se connecter à soi même
donc il ya ceux il ya ce qu'elle est je
hais ce double jeu
mais qu'entend dans un théâtre on est un
pay buy side yahia de la connexion il
doit y avoir de la déconnexion c'est
cette espèce de connexion et un français
quand on fait un sport il était vraiment
on se déconnecte un peu de si on se
déconnecte pas on n'est pas bien mais
c'est surtout quand on se connecte à soi
ce que je pense quand on fait des
typiquement dans le golfe on se connecte
à soi qu'est-ce qui quels sont les
événements culturels qui vous ont marqué
cette année
oulaï beaucoup de façons plus que vous
avez cédé non mais globalement
globalement bas le changement du
ministre du ministre de la culture est
un événement culturel est tombé avec
avec un profil un peu plus politique
donc plus intéressant est certainement
une meilleure connaissance du spectacle
et des arts vivants
il ya la directive européenne sur les
droits d'auteur quittant risquent ils
pas encore en application à qui entrait
en application je crois que on a on a
deux ans pour le point d'intégrer au
droit national qui est un point
important parce que c'était une
l'ugtt qui a duré pendant trois ans ou
quatre ans et le parlement a finalement
voté pas une majorité est super large au
demeurant n'a voté ce texte qui permet
aux auteurs aux créateurs de contenu
leblond les journalistes de recevoir le
fruit de leur travail
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui a eu comme autre événement
que des choses qui m'ont marqué cette
saison une nouvelle génération de
deux chanteuses par exemple je repensais
je pensais victoires de la musique une
nouvelle génération qui est en train de
chanteuse hyper doué qui arrive qui ont
20 ans 25 ans les victoires de john john
ghz
oui mais la promenade à la 30e ou et 35
ans de carrière de carrière donc une
nouvelle génération de chanteuses qui
est vraiment prennent le pouvoir
qu'est-ce qui a d'autres qui je crois
que vous êtes intervenu alors c'est ça
notre dame à moi que vous êtes rattaché
au parlement là dessus
oui alors sur un sujet qui est qui et
tout petit par rapport aux lois et fille
qui est arrivé dans l'hémicycle mais là
c'était plus un exercice démocratique
c'est que j'ai une suggestion de la part
d'un habitant de la ville du pec qui m'a
dit finalement nous on est prêt à donner
il ya un grand élan national et au delà
de nos frontières et on aimerait que la
mémoire en soit conservée et donc à
proposer un espèce de livres d'or
dans lequel est alors donc moi je posais
l'amendement tels que cet habitant me
laver de ma circonscription l'avait
proposé d'envoyer c'était parce que je
pense que c'est un événement qui a
touché mais c'est tout le monde j'étais
surpris par ce bâtiment donc penser que
et que sans aucune reconduit
considérations religieuses
il a dit seulement voilà nous on
voudrait que le nom des donateurs
même s'ils ont donné peu main parce
qu'ils donnent une vingtaine de millions
apparaissent quelque part soit inscrit
pour pour l'éternité
donc je pense qu'avec les moyens
numériques on peut faire ça avoir une
petite tablette ou mai mais j'ai trouvé
ça touchant voyez c'est ça c'est c'était
là là mon intervention
sinon bien sûr comme tout le monde nous
avons été frappés j'étais à paris ce
soir là j'ai vu la forte la fumée monter
en 18h56 sortie de l'hémicycle pour
aller une réunion dans le 5e et on a été
là la rue de l'université on a vu ce qui
s'engouffre et très très très bizarre
avec des odeurs très bizarre j'ai su
après que c'était une odeur de soufre
qui se dégageait et ça a été la
consternation la consternation
consternation et en même temps une de
mobilisation et
une sorte d'unanimité en fait c'est
assez rare les des mouvements
unanimement comme ça la coupe du monde
2010 mai dernier
voilà il y avait du monde sportif il ya
peut-être le que ce parc du château de
versailles vous savez énormément de
donateurs américains lorsqu'ils la
fameuse tempête
oui en 2020 alors examiner une
mobilisation très très fort on assiste
un grand témoin aussi quand
malheureusement on a des soldats qui
disparaissent enfin on arrive à avoir
des moments de communion nationale mais
à travers le sport c'est la preuve c'est
la première illustration des moments
joyeux et des moments de grande
tristesse la presse que l'un deux
raisons on est plein de raisons je sais
pas si on peut parler d'unanimité parce
qu'il ya plein de raisons différentes
qui ont fait que on a été touchés ou le
lait français était touché par ça il ya
ceux pour qui notre dame représentait un
symbole du catholicisme il ya ceux qui
voyaient ça va dépasser ça quand même
non il ya ceux qui voyaient ce menu ce c
'est ce monument comme représentant la
france représentant paris représente
l'histoire représente certainement une
grande culture
il ya ceux qui ont vu aussi dans cet
événement une sorte de symbole de
l'effondrement des fondements de la
france d'où toutes les feuilles qu'il ya
même eu un temps complotisme
vous ne combattez widmore d'abord à vous
à tous et merci au père va évidemment
c'est comme comme comme pour tout le
monde je n'ose c'est vraiment une
édifice qui est qu'ils représentent
après un vrai débat à savoir les skis
pour construire à l'identique août face
à ces demandes et oui oui c'est un débat
très ouvert à mon avis oui sauvegarder
faut garder ouais enfin un moment va
falloir reconstruire
oui on a bien fermé j'ai trouvé
intéressant là justement le fait de dire
ben il faut le faire en cinq ans je
trouvais ça plutôt tendre une volonté
voilà paraître pas uniquement une
volonté mais on sort on se relève dans
les vins on dit on se fait que ces
objectifs clairs mais peut-être en
viendra pas mais au moins ça donne une
impulsion de ne pas diverger de ne pas
attendre dix ans les plans bondi au bout
de la ryder cup quand même oui hein
qu'est ce que c'est alors parce que ça
vous aide notre nappe du golfe
notre-dame du cros avec avec comme ça
c'est une flèche qui monte qui monte
très haut
non mais ça vous apprécie pas mal de
temps beaucoup d'années de travail avant
l'organisation de cet événement aux
galeries nationales que nous dit que
j'ai donc vous étiez inquiets pas
tellement inquiet je vous ai pas trouvé
tellement écrit juste avant non non
c'était c'était pas possible d'être
inquiet parce que effectivement il n'ya
pas uniquement le golf national mais il
ya la fédération française de golf avec
l'équipe de pascal grizot et tout le
monde s'est mis en marche depuis
longtemps depuis cinq ans je dois
absolument c'est pour faire plaisir et
mais c'est vrai que c'était tellement
bien organisé avec tous les corps de
l'état d'ailleurs qui en jouent un rôle
était important sécurité transport donc
le plan je veux dire on ne pouvait pas
avoir des regrets après l'événement
sinon ça ne marchait pas parce qu'on a
tous tout était fait le terrassement etc
le succès phénoménal absolument j'ai un
rapport devant moi qui qui justement qui
donne quelques indications et de deux
des retombées économiques pour la
richesse du pays justement
donc on est au delà de 250 millions
d'euros
sur le plan local au niveau de tout à
fait directement lié à l'événement donc
après maintenant il ya les retombées qui
qui continue à le golf national
aujourd'hui c'est c'est
vous voyez là la conséquence de sa dans
la fréquentation étrangère des musulmans
nous on va monter d'environ 1000
visiteurs étrangers en 2014 à plus de
12000 cette année donc c'est ça qui est
phénoménal parce que c'est des nuitées
d'hôtel c'est cdrv bars et des visites à
paris c'est des visites de notre dame
c'est c'est tout ce qui entoure le
tourisme alors il peut y avoir des
touristes étrangers qui devait venir de
toute façon à paris mais maintenant
qu'ils veulent prendre les clubs parce
que on a un des meilleurs parcours du
monde qui est dans différents tant que
tel mais la plus grosse partie ccd
nouveaux clients nouveaux clients il
français français toujours oui oui tout
à fait alors on a quand même
réactualisé notre politique je dirais
commerciales notre tarification mais
depuis 4 5 ans qui qui a été bien au mal
perçu c'est que la qualité évidemment ça
y est pris ben spies a un prix
je relirai et et et d'un golf qui qui
peut proposer pour tous les types de
golfeurs que ce soit les débutants avec
ou
des gens ayant moins de ressources on en
est un golf ouvert à tout le monde avec
moise les neuf trous à partir de 10
euros la partie on peut jouer comme ça
mais l'albatros le bijou le joyau du
golf français maintenant il a un certain
coût donc là on n'a pas nécessairement
les locaux régionaux qui viennent tous
les week-ends jouer sur l'albatros donc
il ya des résultats un bravo vous la
fais les i très justement vous avez
accordé une interview au journal
l'équipe dans lequel vous de cette
semaine dans lequel vous parlez du stand
la consommation des changements enfin
justement dans la consommation des colts
vous justifiez l'élévation du prix pour
le pour le parcours le plus reconnu ce
qu'il est question de live arcade qui
sera suivie de l'open de france en
octobre et des jeux olympiques en 2024
et celui de l'albatros
et vous dites qu'on est en train de voir
il ya un changement est dans la
consommation et dans l'accueil aussi
dans les golfs et que tout ça est
totalement nécessaire c'est à dire que
c'est plus à peine 2 d'avoir des gens
qui seront employés à rester derrière un
derrière un comptoir comme ça nombre de
clients il faut qu'ils fassent autre
chose
vous êtes beaucoup aidé par le par
l'internet
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya un vrai
changement alors oui c'est un changement
qui est nécessaire c'est une vision
assez personnelle de deux pas de la
pratique du golf parce que je pense que
le golf restera le golfe on va pas dire
la façon devenant va pas changer la
façon de jouer et puis le golfe ne
plaira pas à tout le monde comment tu
verras tout le monde
et d'ailleurs on serait bien bien
embarrassé si toulouse parce qu'on n'a
pas assez d'équipements france mais
notre objectif justement cette
développer ce sport et et de développer
ce sport pour les 50 ans à venir
il faut qu'on change le mode de
consommation surtout pas nécessairement
le sport mais mais il faut qu'on le joue
en moins de temps
il faut qu'on sait pas nécessairement
une question de prix parce que je prends
mon exemple personnel
salle de gym là où on est actuellement
me coûte aussi cher qu'un mois de golf
voit la salle de gym digne de ce nom là
c'est plus cher que le golf mais ça on a
du mal à le faire connaître vous à voir
au public français il ya une image et
une image d'anciennes temps où on a déjà
changé on est révolu des golf privé dans
les années 60-70 qui était plutôt
réservé à une élite c'est vrai
maintenant on a une économie de 40 ans
40 ans on a diversifié là quelques golf
avec et qui coûté extrêmement cher et
pouvoir les une étape complémentaire de
deux camps il faut qu'on change de
consommation il faut qu'on parle le
mieux aux jeunes le golf 1 et super
avantage par rapport à d'autres sports
c'est que ça peut se pratiquer de 8 ans
à 88 ans et intergénérationnelle il ne
peut pas jouer avec son grand-père au
tennis au moins n'est pas à pas très fin
très bien on a des avantages pour tisser
garder ses liens familiaux des choses
comme ça qu'il faut qu'on mette en avant
et pour ça il faut créer les produits
nécessaires alors il y avait et devenir
plus modernes dans notre approche il dit
plus jeunes il y avait dans l'équipe ou
s'il y avait une autre interview de gens
qui s'occupent de parcours de golf et
qui parle et l'impératif environnemental
c'est vrai dans les années 70 ça a été
un peu abandonnés on a fait des trucs
très verte rainbow m'a charmé qui
utilisait beaucoup de deux produits
qu'on ne peut plus utilisés aujourd'hui
là aussi il faut aller il faut aller
vers des choses plus naturel et où la
nature reprend le dessus quoi les dates
heures exemple on est à fond
complètement à fond
je pense qu'aussi un problème déficit de
communication là dessus parce qu'un golf
par mètre carré ou hectares
et moins polluant qu'un terrain de foot
oui tout à fait aujourd'hui il ya des
benchmark en belgique en wallonie où ils
sont déjà à zéro phyto ça marche très
bien les golfs sont beaux c'est possible
c'est tout ça c'est possible c'est
augustin c'est à dire sur un autre
continent numérique c'est un commando
d'élite
voilà c'est un lieu qui qui seront très
bien à la télévision et qu'on a tous
envie de jouer et moi même je dirais pas
le contraire mais ce n'est pas le modèle
ce n'est pas le modèle comme elle le
golf national qui qui est un équipement
je rappelle la fédération française de
golf donc qui doit être leader dans tous
les domaines d'activités que ce soit la
partie commerciale ou la partie
environnementale et on l'est avec un
partenariat avec le muséum d'histoire
naturelle qui nous a obligés qui nous
force à penser à la faune et flore est
ce qu'on enlève est ce qu'on remet les
travaux pour la ryder cup justement nous
nous en
et des réveillons de consommation
d'autres 35% d'un ce extraordinaire et
il faut savoir que sur un golf via un
green qui représente environ sur le golf
national 5% de la surface
et quand il ya des restrictions d'eau en
eux narus que ça voilà là puisque l on
n'arrose pas vers le le le
on ne peut les faire mais voilà on peut
sur l'aigle dans le parcours des petits
vents donc il ya des changements qui
sautent qui sont courts et absolument et
on va aller de plus en plus vers vers
une situation de 2,00 phyto et comme je
dis il ya d'autres pays qui ont réussi
ou des partis des pays où elle a dit je
pense à ça actuellement parce qu'ils
sont vraiment à zéro phyto sûr
alors on a un problème quand même on a
un impact écologique qui qui est assez
complexe pour un golf parce que par
exemple on peut être en voisinage avec
un champ agricole qui peut déverser
interview à cinq mètres d'un golf et
avec le vent on prend les produits qu'il
a qui sont illégaux entre guillemets ou
pas pas permis je me désole m
mais l'hexagone était osé mais le golf
national est une référence pour le
respect de la bravo de diffuser les
bonnes pratiques parce que effectivement
on a pas rien sans rien c'est à dire
qu'il faut des investissements assez
important pour passer à une nouvelle
façon d'entretenir et de cultiver et
donc
là où ce fonds d investissement se
développent des bonnes pratiques que
l'on peut peut-être étendre
effectivement aux céréaliers qui jouxte
de le golf voilà il ya des réflexions de
territoire entre autres acteurs sûr
qu'ils manipulent la manière la matière
verte voilà il ya des démarches de tri
il ya des démarches vous allez à la
boutique du golf national et je vous
invite tous à venir d'ailleurs et vous
pouvez acheter notre propre miel qui est
fait avec des musulmans dans notre
boutique c'est pas une grosse grosse
quantité mais en a effectivement des
abbés bail glissant en partenariat avec
les entreprises qui sont la cub parce
que notre personnel ne peut pas mais
effectivement on a tout genre de
démarche et et on devrait justement
organisé des visites mais bien de ceux
du thème de l'environnement
c'est à vous avez présenté il ya peu de
temps la la la nouvelle saison 1 de
saint quentin
comment construit une saison là vous
partez pour avignon par exemple dans le
suppose oui ça se construit toute
l'année on fait ça a commencé depuis un
mois à travailler sur la saison 2020
oui ça se construit par voilà on est
trois affaires la programmation votée à
de 50 ans donc on voit chacun
environ 200 spectacles par par saison on
a des rendez vous quotidien avec des
artistes et qui nous parlent qu'ils nous
parlent de leurs de leurs projets leurs
projections en production voilà on a
tout 7,7 cette matière là et puis après
on essaie de trouver un équilibre comme
c on est dans la place qu'on appelle la
pluridisciplinarité c'est à dire on est
sur les la danse le théâtre et la houle
et musique le cirque contemporain
on essaie de trouver cet équilibre on
essaie de trouver aussi cet équilibre
entre les hommes et les femmes
on essaie de faire en sorte que la
diversité dont l'agresseur de la société
française soit aussi représentée sur le
plateau comment est ce que des gens qui
sont dans la salle peuvent se
reconnaître aussi sur le sur le plateau
ça c'est un point important
et puis après il ya forcément une part
de subjectivité de goût personnel qui
entrent en ligne de compte
voilà un autre visage frappant quand
même c'est le succès dans une population
qui n'est pas forcément un a priori
comme ça fait pour ça non je sais pas si
c'est je sais pas si ces frappes en fait
on travaille beaucoup et programmation
exigeante et qui attire un grand public
quand même fier que son officine
je vous entends mais c'est vrai que vend
des hommages il non il est toujours très
surprenant pour moi pour nous lorsque
des spectateurs prennent un abonnement
de voir que sur 15 10 ou 15 spectacle
qu'ils vont qui vont sélectionner y en a
peut-être un artiste qui le connaissent
mais c'est un spectacle qui connaissent
et donc ils se laissent ils se laissent
guider était tout notre travail c'est
aussi de tisser cette relation de
ce contrat de confiance c'est comme ça
qu'on dit cette relation de confiance
avec les spectateurs
c'est à dire qu'ils aient après ils
peuvent être déçus mais le côté déceptif
fait aussi partie du fait aussi partir
d'une du métier de dictateur dont on va
au stade stade quoi l'appareil se
trouvait au théâtre sinon peut être oui
non si ça mais je pense que ce dernier
comme disent les suisses
quand on fait nous notre notre travail
c'est de c'est de faire en sorte que les
poser des gens viennent voir des choses
qu'ils ne savent pas qu'ils vont aimer
non c'est ouvrir la voie on n'a pas le
temps de parler des projets évidemment
il ya la réforme des retraites y aller
il ya la peine pour tous ept qui vont
être des sujets importants mais on va
peut-être par les deux pays reste à
peine trois minutes et demie peut-être
de politique locale il ya les élections
municipales la république en marche
n'est pas représentée en tant que telle
le modem les un peu plus votre allié
dans certaines municipalités
comment ça va se passer vous avez des
liens déjà des stratégies qui sont mises
en place
vous allez soutenir certains candidats
vous allez présenter des candidats il ya
quand même des élus qui sont déjà en
poste dans des conseils municipaux qui
pourrait allier la république en harry
reid et ce depuis le depuis l'uss depuis
donc on a en a une
voilà une petite base d'élus mais bien
sûr comme nous sommes un mouvement
nouveau il va falloir approfondir sa et
donc on considère le temps le dira aux
qualités des villes soit en menant
directement des listes soit en
inscrivant dans des en inscrivant des
ddd des candidats dans des listes dont
le la tête de lice nous paraît tout à
fait partager les mêmes valeurs c'est
une histoire de valeur c'est pas une
histoire de deux effectivement de carte
politique stricto senso c'est c'est bien
sûr sur des valeurs je dirais de centre
un centriste et d'ouverture à l'europe
d'ouverture à la culture d'ouverture la
diversité qu'on pourra se rallier
justement
à des projets présentés par par des
maires il faut savoir qu'il ya beaucoup
de petites communes aussi dans les
yvelines où les mères ne se repose on ne
se présente pas du tout comme étant
affilié à partir et ce sont des listes
de rassemblement et donc on sera content
d'en mener certaines listes en ayant une
grande ouverture et puis ou de rejoindre
des listes de rassemblement s'est pas
desserrée en ce moment ci lever 6,6 en
avance on a déjà vous avez vous voulu
présenter basse et par médecin
généraliste
on a déjà de tête de ramos et sans nous
avons
aussi à rambouillet et puis le reste ce
qui n'est pas annoncée n'est pas
annoncée ici mais mais mais mais on y
travaille on ecully les dossiers un par
un et c'est la commission de visionnage
de marché dans les zones m'amusant oui
oui tout à fait dent dure contre les
choix qui sont qui sont affirmés mais
vous avez aussi
voilà des ddd des décisions qu'il faut
laisser le temps à la commission
nationale d'investiture de se prononcer
et pour les villes de plus de 9000
habitants c'est normal et et beaucoup de
voile à deux projets qui se mettent en
place dans les différentes villes ça
avance on va parce que c'est vrai
véritablement à la rentrée moi je
n'exclus pas d'être sur une liste mais
pas d'emmener une sas et non pas mais on
a encore trois ans de mandat de député
est-ce que vous projetez après parce que
vous disiez vous des prunes
professionnel vous et faire de la
politique est ce que vous dites tiens
monde assez bien où est ce qu'il faut en
faire un autre pour avoir plus de
réussite et vous si j'ai encore de la
valeur ajoutée je jugerai jeu vraiment
un examen de conscience à 7 à cette
échéance là bien sûr que je poursuivrai
c'est parce que la politique c'est pas
c'est pas venu il ya seulement deux ans
moi ça s'inscrit dans un parfum de toute
ma vie je me suis intéressé à ça j'ai
participé à des 70 j'avais pas forcément
ma carte dans un parti
j'ai fait une campagne municipale en
2001 voyez donc c'est quand même pas
quelque chose que voilà que l'on
embrasse du jour au lendemain et que
l'on qui n'ont jeu de près ou de loin je
m'intéresserai toujours à l'appétit et
j'espère pouvoir continuer que son
meilleur lancer sans merci beaucoup
d'ateliers plus virèrent si merci
beaucoup lionel de cet homme c'est
beaucoup pas l'héritage est brave ou
alors
vos actions et ben voilà l'émission est
terminée a très vite pour nouveau paf ça
sera probablement à la rentrée en
septembre
[Musique]